[Music]
you know you're the interviewer but like
my question is leave everybody one quit
yeah everybody's one question yeah what
are you seeing because I would I really
feel from you when I look at your
interviews when I look at your Twitter
feed is like you have a sort of a
relentless pursuit of the truth right
now you're willing to criticize any and
everyone you're willing to just say like
CNN got it wrong here Fox News got it
wrong here fuctions got it right here
yeah you know and I really appreciate
that what what are you seeing you know
on the right in terms of people that are
doing that that I can point my friends
to and say can I can i really i can put
my friends to you in dispute oh this is
great
you know we've had we got the gay Jewish
male losing himself a liberal as a
liberal who wants to be there he's
really fair like go check them out and
this traction yeah who else is doing
this right now that I can pin out so I
think that if you want to show somebody
what what a good conservative yeah like
a conservative who makes consistently
logical center and and who isn't going
to just drub you over the head endlessly
i think ben shapiro is the best example
of that we absolutely have our
differences yes policies policy wise and
that kind of stuff and we actually agree
on a lot of things you but i think he
knows what he's talking about and he's
not doing things for points
so you'll see him call out trump as
often as he calls out the rest in a way
he actually calls out Trump more than I
do I've been my feelings with Trump are
because of the level of hysteria that
everyone is putting out there right that
I've tried to control my hysteria
because I don't think it helps
everyone's doing it so for example he's
been president now for you know good so
about 80 days or so and it's like I
actually don't know of major things that
he's done to be hysterical about so like
cutting things like the kind of you know
the art stuff they cut like 800 million
from the humanities some rather hmm
now I love art I got some good art
around here and in the house and I'll
and I know artists my sister's an artist
the idea that the government right has
to fund art and that we have to just
involuntarily be taxed to give money
that I believe that if that disappeared
that it wouldn't hurt art it might help
art because part of being an artist is
having to deal with the struggle and
perhaps that when the government does it
then the things that get to the museums
are really because of political
connections and financial connectors I
don't know about all that I'm not our
expert in this field but some of those
things when people say he's cutting all
of this stuff now if you're going to cut
meals-on-wheels that people absolutely
need and we don't know yet that private
charities will come in right that's also
the rub with that that people always say
well no private charities aren't can do
it but we have to give them a chance
here too so that's why I haven't been
too hysterical I don't sense we're going
to war with Russia but if the Democrats
were and we might be because they seem
to think we've called a fake Russian
presidents all right you know he was
designed for the gays you know there was
all this gay hysteria
did you know they canceled the gay pride
parade in LA this year yeah it's going
to be a protested but what had he done
against gay people he got a standing
ovation talking about gay people at the
convention allow me to refill your watch
yes thank you sir if you were if you
were like because you're in this middle
ground that's interesting like if you if
you're kind of looking around this
budget you're seeing all this defense
spending that's kind of popping up and
you're seeing money coming away from
from the arts like do you think that
that's a good move for us or would you
be like well maybe we can still do meals
on wheels and do a little less in the
military like ya know I would do you
think about that appropriation I mean if
you right so first off again I'm not an
economist yeah I could just give you the
broad sense of what I think is a Scalia
right we it's a spending issue so I had
Austin Peterson on yesterday I think
actually the interview is going to air
after we do this so it's a little little
confusing cuz it's very back to the
future but but he ran as a libertarian
candidate lost to Gary Johnson and that
whole thing was a disaster but that's
for another show he was saying that just
just start trimming pennies on
everything across the board okay so that
when you go for the arts or you go for
meals on wheels and people see a hatchet
that data it adds to the hysteria right
so if you're somebody on the left and
you see Trump do that it's like he's the
big glass it's anger he was just going
for the trigger and then you go
hysterical
the right base coats you see how we
figured these hysterical lunatics and
the snowflakes are melting and all and
so what what Austin was saying was
basically just start trimming little
bits each year and that what you realize
is you know the government they do all
these crazy things where they have to
spend all my money or their budgets
don't you I mean Hollywood does that
kind of thing we don't spend it or don't
get our bags where is it dump it yeah
right so they keep making these Michael
Page ya know you feel about Abby's
movies keep getting bigger and more
expensive and you know they don't get
any better and I humble opinion you're
not alone yeah all right I used to love
the Transformers I grew up on you
probably you're the same age of yeah oh
that was my jam yeah everything that I
believed I learned in this area Optimus
Prime be president I would vote for
Optimus Prime for he turned out too much
time into a complete psychopath used to
be moral decent human forthright and he
had that nice solid deep voice not great
loyal you know great voice anyway so
something about these little
incrementals across the board yeah could
we cut 20% of our military spending
probably tomorrow now a lot of people
would be upset with that name probably
do a lot with jobs but little JEP slowly
being like guys this year we're cutting
the whole thing 3% we're going to try it
again next year and it is all hell I'm
going to break loose yeah probably not
so I would be for something like that
yeah I'm so you're not happening for
some reason I don't know why well it's
kind of because it kind of sounds too
sensible yeah you know to me like who
would come in that's part of the problem
right now right that if you come in with
a sensible answer yeah what the hell is
this guy talking about what's what's the
end what's the incentive I don't know I
guess I just don't understand that you
know I mean I look at like I look at the
lot of the oil pipeline stuff and it's
like this is jobs creation and then I'm
like well if the facts that I'm reading
are true there's a lot of these
temporary jobs but it's like this is a
really only 35 permanent jobs that we're
creating here and so what is your what
is your initiative and lifting these
restrictions is it really about your
deep level credo that government should
be backed off or used to standing behind
that so you can get some secure word
from some of these oil guys and I'll
never be able to understand that and I
feel like a lot of people in my position
are feeling that way in all fairness I
think that I'm willing to give a little
more attempt to listen in here where a
lot of
most liberals that I know are just like
oil money he's just taking his oil might
any saying it's for jobs and he's saying
it's for deregulation but that's
[ __ ] yeah you know well they to that
like what it what is the answer to that
I don't know I don't know exactly what
you know other than things are probably
a little more complex than than what
they're just taken up and just taking
the bra right then you know I'll see I
see this on both sides I know they'll
you know a Democrat does something that
people that the Republicans are like and
then Republicans will tweet out but he
took $2,000 from the book and then they
do it the other way too and it's like
pretty sure they're not being bought off
for $2,000 now it's not 2,000 bucks now
look at the end of the day if goldman
sachs is giving hillary a hundred
thousand for speech whatever it was i
think it maybe was 250 yeah it probably
has a little something-something in that
influence you know but i would say even
beyond the money it's just the the
collusion of all of these people going -
you know what this is like a hollywood
even like all these people going to the
same parties being around the same
people everyone likes to take a picture
in front of the step in reminding
percent with the celebrity with the
positive ends up conscious like on
hugely i don't think they realize it but
you know when they're doing it but
that's actually a great segue to just
Hollywood in general related to all of
this so as you've been talking about
this you've mentioned sort of your
friend circles and things like that
are you privately getting pushback from
people so I'm getting mostly really
positive responses when when they talk
about the theory 30,000 foot theory
let's reach across the aisle let's focus
on what we share as opposed to our
differences and let's try to build
bridges okay that is very hard to malign
no one really gets upset about that but
that's the base level you know then
there's like the next level when I sort
of as opposed to tweeting out a damning
tweet for cutting meals-on-wheels but
send out like so a genuine question for
conservatives out there who support this
do you really believe that the private
sector is going to come in do you think
that hopefully they'll come in but I
kind of don't care if they don't get
rather put the money somewhere else
there are a couple people who say to me
like why are you dipping your toe in the
waters of enabling here why don't you
use your voice to just say these are old
people who need
food and need attention and we need to
support that and and so I understand
that so that so it really comes down to
intentions right because your your
intention is to really figure out what
people are thinking major percent and it
sort of goes back to what we talked to a
few minutes so there's no way of knowing
unless if the government stopped doing
that would someone say one SEPA and
would they not and then are we willing
to deal with the ramifications if they
you know and for my choice like I would
rather not take that risk I would rather
know for sure that like the government
is putting the money there and I also
don't fully trust that if people get
their money back trickle-down that
they're going to actually give that's
just a me being a little probably
cynical but at the same time I am that's
why I'm trying to run these little tests
model campaigns to see again I'm not
saving the world right now I'm doing
turning ten thousand of my own dollars
into forty thousand dollars it's not
putting a dent in anything but it's the
microcosm that can work and I can get
some data that says like holy [ __ ] I
didn't like youth like you might believe
I didn't realize how much people would
really give from the private sector when
they know it's not happening from
government and the Conservatives were
not just hiding behind that they really
will do it more vice versa you know they
just say that they wanted to give in the
private sector but they're not going to
do it yeah I don't know yet you know but
if I can figure that out and get some
data on that I think that there's
possibility to do some some bigger
things and in my mind again this is
thinking way far ahead but like if we
can provide this bedrock of safety so
that says like okay Democrats are in
power they're going to tax the [ __ ] out
of everybody and they're going to give
to HUD they're going to give to the arts
are going to over give it's going to be
not fully efficient as liberal I'm
willing to accept that it might not be
efficient that doesn't mean I should
pull the rug out from under it I'd
rather have a non efficient thing than a
nonentity so that's going to happen then
okay now there's a conservative in power
we're cutting all those programs you sir
saving eight to ten percent on your
taxes I want you to give half of that
back efficiently into those programs and
we're still going to keep those programs
afoot so that basically yeah plus or
minus where the money is coming from
we're kind of juggling these things and
keeping them afloat you're a social
science I'm a social and my my true
belief in all of this and it's just
based on my own experience is that
giving is infectious and once you start
to open your eyes to the space as a
great book called strangers drowning
that's about what happens when you enter
this space and how it is so infectious
in fact that it can destroy you once you
start to realize how many people could
use help and there it's a stories of
people who literally just give away
everything they have because I got too
caught into it I have conversations with
my wife constantly which is like she's
like my Oprah what don't make me the
abyssal who have to stop you from giving
like alright what the brakes on a little
bit here because we can get a little bit
crazy yeah but when I just know when I
talk to people who have gotten involved
and they see where that dollar goes that
you start to realize oh my god I can do
so much good with this so my hope is
that you know eventually we could depend
on the private sector to be a baseline
giving Perennial in the event that we
have a conservative government once cut
those programs yeah yeah what about just
the general morals that we get from
Hollywood as a guy that makes please you
make movies literally at every level of
moviemaking that people you know part of
there's a certain segment of society
that thinks we should get moral or
whether we should or shouldn't we do one
way around you get a certain moral code
from movies yeah and I think a lot of
people think there's a there's like
secret meetings in Holley right where
they're sitting around I mean people
really believe it that they're sitting
around going which what can we push yeah
I see a lot of the social justice that
they push out that I don't like I
mentioned to you before we started that
I just finished transparent with your
brother done I just finished it last
night and when I started watching it
just ten days ago or something I thought
it was going to be social justice
Palooza I really did but it wasn't yeah
they actually pushed back on it in spite
it being about a trans family I
understand of LGBT stuff and and some
interesting Rachel so I mean all over
the place yeah and they did it so for
somebody that is in Holly this are you
know it involved in secret meetings
actually engineer the society so look I
I will admittedly tell you I am NOT in
the top-level meetings with you know the
paramount executives and 150,000 150
million dollar movie you know but I am
involved in quite a bit
and this is what this is what I see
honestly and you know it's going to
sound a little bit biased but the only
people I know who are truly making like
really agenda-driven films that don't
show any fairness in the antagonists the
only films I have seen that truly do
that are coming from the extreme
religious sector of filmmaking people
who make movies like God's not dead and
such like that where they where it's
literally like an an ran novel yeah or
you know one of those like classic old
philosophical speeches from you know
platonic methods over in a cave and and
there's and they're coming out to have
someone prove to someone else on the
screen why they're wrong and that's an
agenda later film my opinion I don't
have a problem with that film being made
I don't have a problem with that feeling
going at the audience's who love it and
bussing in the people I want to see the
movie I have no problem with that being
made from just a purely free speech
standpoint but what an evolved opinion
you're actually something comes out you
don't like you won't see it you're not
going to try to burn down a video it's
totally wonderful now I do see agenda
oriented films from the left I do see
movies that come out and say like my
goal here is a tell a great story but at
the same time I want to show you a young
gay black male protagonist who you may
not normally have gotten to know in your
life and normalize him and make him feel
at home with you so that is an agenda
but also in that film I do I do feel
like most of the time there's a fairness
address to all the characters even the
antagonist who comes at that person who
if there's an attempt to be a nuance
there that's the independent filmmaking
sphere that's you know sure what I what
I see but what I can say directly to
anyone who is not in Hollywood please
don't be paranoid they're a group of
people with agendas trying to shove
something down your throat and if you
feel that way just know that it's not
dissimilar to that wonderful religious
film that you enjoyed that you were able
to experience your agenda being pushed
and you enjoyed it and then if you
didn't want that movie you could have
stayed home that's the worst that's ever
going to get yeah well to me it might
when people ask me about this or you
live in Hollywood and I'm like so off I
can take the WB studio tour that was
a little heart you know I wish the
commentary that was very exciting but my
thing is it's that it's a business like
every other business they will make
things that they believe make money and
I think that was almost thinking
probably 99.9% of cases that will
supersede some sort of political agenda
I would say a hundred percent they want
to make money and that's the way a
business is supposed to be yes I mean
what's really interesting right now is
like you know movie like moonlight wins
the Oscar you know I love this movie too
1.5 million dollar movie you know with a
young black young gay black male
protagonists we don't see movies like
this very often they don't get funded
now Hollywood it's just funny to me it's
just like well let's make a whole bunch
of young gay black males in it because
it's money they're not thinking about
that from a social justice perspective
thinking about it from a money
perspective likewise I'm hearing a big
call right now for my fan base saying
like where is the independent film about
the young Rust Belt family that's making
twenty six thousand dollars a year and
the struggles that they face why are all
the struggle movies you're making right
now about the marginalized people
whether it's you know a minority or or
you know whether it's LGBTQ or something
like that I'm hearing like what about me
you know and I and I think that that is
part and parcel with why Trump was
elected you know a lot about a lot of
with that and I think that there is a
valid point to that and I think that
there are you're going to start to see
some stories come out about that yeah I
suspect you might be involved in what
all been a lot of this stuff and I and I
hear a lot of this and it's like I'm
like yes this is another element of
society that we should represent and
it's and it's good you know and I hear
that veterans are not represented enough
you know from the right and stuff like
that so I mean look it's it's all super
nuanced in the independent sphere in
that in the big budget sphere in my
opinion follow the dollar that's just
what they're doing and you know whatever
it's not what I do but it's fine
yeah at the end of the day to kind of
bring this whole circle would the
ultimate answer to this be sort of what
you stated at the beginning that you
know your your grandfather struggles got
your got your father to be in a better
position got you to be in a better
position so that's truly the American
dream but it sounds like you got a lot
of your values out of that
and not a dove Hollywood and that's what
I always try to tell me why would you
look don't look for this to give you
values and you got to find them
somewhere else it might have something
to do with your family or your community
or whatever else yeah I mean look you
know my my sphere of people that I work
with were we're like you know I don't
want to overstate this but like we're
scrappers you know like I still hang
lights on set and I still cook on my
sets for people and like we make I made
a little black-and-white movie with me
and Sarah Paulson that I made for
Netflix for basically no money and then
Netflix pays me a lot of money for those
movies and I make this huge check and
then I take that check and I cut bonus
checks to everyone who was on the set
with me including the PAS mm-hmm and so
in that way I'm actually a comedy you
know I'm all over the map you know Korea
but like you know for those who think
Hollywood is just like a greedy system
that's all about money making and and
all this stuff like there are ecosystems
of wonderful people out here who are you
know using their power to to uh produce
and foster young filmmakers and raise
them up and to say you know look I mean
when I did a movie called your sister
sister wouldn't with Emily Blunt
Rosemarie DeWitt and myself we made it
for really cheaply we happen to sell it
for a lot of money the three of us made
a ton of it and I went to the girls and
I'll get some money back to the crew
let's give some money back to Seattle
and that filmmaking environment and like
we gave away half of what we made and it
filtered in that community and and this
stuff is going on and you might not see
it because the you know shits loud and
incendiary on Twitter from Hollywood
like some good-hearted people out here
we care we're trying to listen and you
know I would just say if you're if
you're a conservative watching this show
like please don't think that everyone
thinks you're a racist and everyone is
yelling it there are a couple people
yelling that you know and by the way
there are a couple people yelling at me
for being a [ __ ] baby killer because
you know I want to support any
organization that has to do with
abortions you know I'm getting yelled at
too you're getting yelled at don't
believe that that represents everybody
there's a lot of space in the middle for
us to come together yeah
you know how to end a show that was
pretty sad I'm going to be real quiet
and then just enema you zoom in slowly
on my face yeah you just did your own
sort of Fountainhead style I think it
wasn't well off the music steel right
yes
live event it was a pleasure talking to
you I suspected me I suspected we were
going to kind of vibe in this way and I
absolutely if you want some help on this
thing I would love it and I'm going to
come back to you and hit you hard
because it's you I saw he's going to
give we don't hit it they don't there's
nothing I could do
for more on Mark and his interesting
political voyage check them out on
twitter at twitter.com/dspacestv
[Music]
you